a
[Música]
ah
una de las grandes promesas de joe biden
durante toda su campaña electoral para
atraer a la población latina tiene que
ver con la cuestión migratoria
el demócrata prometió aprobar un
proyecto de ley de inmigración desde el
minuto 1 en que llegara a la casa blanca
su propuesta no pasa por abrir
completamente las fronteras de eeuu pero
sí pudo regularizar la situación de
cerca de 11 millones de indocumentados
que viven en este país una propuesta que
apunta a que todas aquellas personas que
vivan de manera ilegal en eeuu desde el
1 de enero del 2021
podrían acceder a regularizar su estatus
legal e incluso a conseguir una tarjeta
permanente siempre que no tengan
antecedentes penales que hayan pagado
sus impuestos y reúnan una serie de
requisitos esa vía sería mucho más
rápida para aquellas personas que se
encuentran con una protección legal
temporal o para los llamados gamers los
soñadores esos jóvenes que llegaron a
eeuu de manera ilegal cuando tan sólo
eran unos niños
[Música]
el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador ha hecho un llamado al
presidente entrante de los eeuu joe
biden a llevar a cabo una reforma
migratoria integral llegó el tiempo de
cumplir con ese compromiso dijo el
mandatario mexicano horas antes del
relevo en la casa blanca así las
esperanzas de millones de connacionales
indocumentados en la unión americana
están puestas en el plan migratorio que
la administración byd en defender ante
el congreso estadounidense y que implica
un camino más corto a la ciudadanía el
tema migratorio ha sido abordado en la
única conversación telefónica que
tuvieron lópez obrador y byd en antes de
su asunción mientras tanto de la parte
mexicana de acuerdo con la secretaria de
gobernacion olga sánchez cordero mexico
alista un plan para atender a millones
de centroamericanos solicitantes de
asilo en estados unidos y que son
obligados a permanecer en territorio
mexicano mientras se resuelve su
petición
[Música]
al presidente by den le espera el reto
de atender el fenómeno de las caravanas
de emigrantes que parten desde el
triángulo norte de centroamérica las
caravanas parten rumbo a eeuu desde 2018
y han seguido a pesar del joven 19 como
la más reciente compuesta por unos nueve
mil hondureños y que fue contenida por
la fuerza en guatemala por policías y
militares la administración saliente de
donald trump creó mecanismos con el
salvador guatemala honduras y méxico
para impedir que los migrantes llegaran
hasta eeuu como los acuerdos de tercer
país seguro un asesor del equipo de
transición de bailén dijo a los
migrantes de la caravana no vengan ahora
la situación en la frontera no va a
cambiar de la noche a la mañana en el
caso de nicaragua otro país
centroamericano emisor de emigrantes que
buscan eeuu como destino
bailén tendrá pendiente aunar a los
esfuerzos internacionales para resolver
la crisis sociopolítica que persiste en
ese país desde 2018 y que ha expulsado a
decenas de miles de nicaragüenses
[Música]